als tatort pathologe professor boerne
kennt er tod und leid aus seinen rekord
vermisst die millionen lieben jan josef
liefers beschäftigen diese themen nicht
nur im scheinwerferlicht vor der kamera
der schauspieler und musiker steht für
eine starke und klare meinung er macht
den mund auf wenn andere schweigen und
das brachte liefers im april auch
heftige kritik ein bei der alles
dichtmachen aktion hatten künstler die
korona politik und berichterstattung
ironisch überspitzt dargestellt einem
besuch auf einer kuh wird
intensivstation habe man ihm daraufhin
abgesagt hieß es er wollte sich selbst
ein bild vor ort machen und das hat er
nun aber doch gemacht und darüber
wirklich eindrucksvoll hierbei bild
geschrieben welche eindrücke ihn
besonders bewegt haben und welche
gedanken geblieben sind was er an der
aktuellen corona und auch politische
situationen nicht versteht dass erzählt
uns jan josef liefers jetzt hier live
bei bild live und deswegen schalten wir
zu eben schönen guten morgen herr
liefers
schön dass sie zeit haben genau die
erste frage an sie direkt wie war es
denn vor ort auf dieser intensivstation
und wie sehr ja wie sehr belastet sie
diese diese bilder immer noch
das war ja eine alte wenn du so willst
bringschuld damals bei ihr habe das ja
schon ein bisschen erwähnt bei alles
dichtmachen da gab es diese forderung
wir sollten doch lieber die klappe
halten und mache auf intensivstationen
gehen und mal hand anlegen und ich habe
für so etwas
keine angst ich weiß ungefähr was auf
intensivstationen los ist mein vater ist
auf einer gestorben ich habe dort viel
zeit zu gebracht aber ich habe trotzdem
gesagt ich mache es dann wurde das fand
das nicht statt weil
nicht wegen mir wie es in der zeitung
stand sondern weil die art und weise mit
kamerateams und so das war einfach zu
viel
der klinikdirektor von essen mit dem
habe ich inzwischen geredet hat mir das
so erklärt also das kam danach andere
kliniken die gesagt haben bei uns wäre
ich wenn sie willkommen und können das
gerne machen und ich bin jemand der
solche einladung gerne an end weil ich
was lernen deutlich kühler werden besser
bescheid wissen und nun habe ich gemacht
und war ich dort und habe tag erwischt
der auch gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich
einer der krassesten war in den letzten
wochen
ich habe alles aufgeschrieben und steht
bei euch in der zeitung und was bei der
x ist auch ein bisschen gekürzt wird was
ich jetzt noch sagen will jetzt dass ich
das mir besonders in erinnerung
geblieben ist die leistungen die die
pflegekräfte auch sondern station
jeden tag bringen und ich habe ein
bisschen mitgeholfen mitgeholfen
umzulagern also einfache dinge zu tun
aber es ist ja vielmehr ist es die
körperpflege es ist das dasein das ist
die menschliche ansprache auch wenn die
menschen dort in einem tiefen schlaf
liegen wird immer mit ihnen gesprochen
und wenn es denn was in den
intensivstationen nun mal auch häufig
passiert zu ende geht dann ist ja fehlen
die verwandten weil unter den pandemie
bedingungen und infektionsschutz dann
wieder gar nicht erlaubt sind und gar
nicht hinkommen können dann übernehmen
die diese aufgabe auch noch also viel
mehr als ihrem pflegerische arbeit
müssen die leisten und bringen auch auf
dem menschlichen leid das geht auch an
denen ich ganz spurlos vorbei also ich
mir ein absolutes rätsel warum das so
ein schlecht bezahlter und
schlecht
wieso das und beruf ist den wir nicht
viel höher schützen
gesprochen haben auch sie da gesehen
wird dann als hausherr brille in dieser
montur was geht ihnen was sind die
bilder die sie da bei dieser erfahrung
besonders bewegt haben sie kam in
berührung mit menschlichen schicksalen
was sind die gedanken die ihnen da jetzt
auch nicht mehr aus dem kopf und aus dem
herzen gehen ich bin hin und hergerissen
weil es gibt natürlich viele gesichter
dieser pandemie und dieser zeit wenn man
auf einer intensivstation ist dann sieht
man natürlich auch ein verzerrtes bild
der realität weil dort liegen einfach um
die schwersten der schwersten fälle und
wenn jetzt auch wirklich jünger das hat
man mir dort bestätigt und es gibt
vorerkrankungen die typisch sind wie zum
beispiel sehr hohes übergewicht was das
alles zu bedeuten hat kann ich nicht ein
und ich bin kein arzt das müssen andere
leute erklären aber es
steckt eben doch leben dahinter und auch
einzelgeschichten die zum glück zum
glück sehr sehr sehr selten sind aber
das wollte ich das hat mich schon
beeindruckt dass die leute die dort
arbeiten aus ihrer sicht auf die dinge
sagen wenn jemand geimpft werden könnte
und dass nun nicht möchte einfach so aus
irgendwelchen gründen die die vielleicht
so aber ich habe keine zeit oder dann
dann verstehen die das nicht das ist das
war mir ich bin fit ich habe mich im
verlassen weil ich erst das ging ich
habe mir das auch nicht leicht gemacht
ich hab mich sehr erkundigt und am ende
abgewogen und meine entscheidung
getroffen und bei mir ist das alles sind
wir auch gut gegangen und ich kenne
keine andere geschichte erzählen als die
ich selbst erlebt habe aber ich weiß
natürlich auch dass wir heute leute die
sich gegen eine impfung entscheiden
massiv unter druck setzen und dass das
ist mir nicht ganz klar warum wir das
tun die regierung hat sich dafür
entschieden keine impfung verpflichtend
zu machen und damit gibt es keinen
vielleicht damit heißt das ist eine
freiwillige sache und leute sozusagen
bis an den rand der erpressung und unter
druck zu setzen und ihn auch zum teil
finanzielle einbußen und und berufliche
nachteile
mitzugeben also dass das ist für mich
unverständlich zumal jetzt habt ihr
selbst gesagt bevor wir angefangen zu
sprechen der im sport haben die ganz
offensichtlich viel viel höher ist
angeblich 90 prozent impfbereitschaft
der menschen in deutschland also was
will man jetzt eigentlich noch und
ich finde es wird an der zeit dass eine
neue regierung oder von mir aus auch
noch die alte die jahren wieder am amtes
hinten eine klare entscheidung trifft
das ist auch wirklich einen
beeindruckender satz der auch hier bei
uns hängen geblieben ist sie haben
gesagt dort haben die pfleger und ärzte
ihn berichtet keiner wäre hiermit
impfung
ja das haben sie gesagt also ich meine
wir wissen nicht genau was diese
impfungen wirklich keine macht ich habe
bei mir in meinem stand es dann richtig
akribischen die noch konto nach
kontrollieren lassen und ich weiß was
ich bei mir gemacht hat aber
wir wissen wohl dass wir uns trotz
impfung infizieren können das glaube ich
kein zweifel daran aber dass die
verläufe eben nicht zustimmen werden und
es gab es doch gerade zwei
gegeben hätten wir diesen über die dann
ihre babys der quasi noch keine not-op
bekommen haben aber die dann selbst die
gesehen haben das hat mich schon was ich
sagen umgehauen und ja wenn man denen
das vorher gesagt wenn man gesagt hätte
ich leute aus wir wissen warum das leute
so hart trifft wir wissen nicht warum
wirklich jemand jetzt es gibt ja auch
übergewichtige menschen die sich
infizieren und nicht krank werden also
das ist ja nicht der einzige kommen wenn
man denen das vorher gesagt hätte das
wird bei euch passieren wir wissen das
weil wir können das auslesen dann hätten
die garten von würde euch davor
gewandelt es ist garantiert gemacht aber
ich meine es sieht ja ganz viele leute
schon öfters tagen ja ganz viele leute
diese entscheidung getroffen und ich
finde die diese entscheidung die ich
treffen muss man genauso respektieren am
ende des tages die sich impfen lassen
haben so wenig
hatte angesprochen herr liefers und das
war auch eine passage in ihrem text der
im übrigen auch noch auf bild de zu
finden ist für alle zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer die den nochmal nachlesen
möchte wo sie über hochschwangere frauen
schreiben sie dort lagen und dann auch
ihre kinder bekommen haben was für
menschen sind ihnen dort begegnet was
für patienten waren dort es geht eine
mir ist nicht nach wenn man das dann
real erlebt
also die details kenne ich auch richtig
dass es gibt eine ärztliche
schweigepflicht und es gibt doch
das dürfte ich gar nicht wissen du nicht
wenn du würde ich auch nicht drüber
reden müssen private geschichten am ende
des tages aber klar sein junge frauen
und das war
ich glaube das bricht einem das herz man
sowas hört und ich war muss ich sagen in
dem moment sprachlos und
es ist nicht leicht sich dann wieder
reinzukriegen un zu sagen man muss das
was man selbst sieht das was an
einzelnen abfall ist ein einzelnes
schicksal das muss man eben auch trennen
kann vom gesamtwert ich meine ich bin
wenn ich vielleicht bin ich mache filme
ich glaube für seinen film ist so eine
geschichte vielleicht geeignet als für
eine schlussfolgerung die auf die ganze
gesellschaft
zählt deswegen würde ich da ganz klein
bleiben an privat bleiben und bei meiner
eigenen meinung und meiner geschichte
oder einfach nur dem was ich erlebt habe
das hat mich allerdings wirklich muss
ich sagen
tief bewegt und getroffen also ja man
merkt dass ihnen auch an was muss ihrer
meinung nach denn jetzt passieren was
muss besser werden was haben sie gesehen
wo man wo man vielleicht sagen kann ja
da gibt es definitiv bedarf das muss
anders laufen ich denke dass der
berufsstand der pflege im krankenhaus
aber auch in der intensivpflege einfach
eine aufwertung bedarf und zwar auch
eine finanziell nicht kann mir es gibt
ja auch dort zum beispiel weil sie stets
so ruhig weil die hat einfach mehr
erwarten aber wir konnten gar nicht
betrieben werden weil niemand da war um
das zu machen das ist es fehlt einfach
an personal und das kann besonders gut
bezahlter job dabei ist es ein job der
wahrscheinlich in zukunft noch viel
wichtiger wird dass er heute denn wir
werden alle immer älter und der umstand
dass wir wahrscheinlich krank werden und
pflege brauchen das nicht von der hand
zu weisen dass es ein klarer fall
sie schreiben auch in ihrem text wir
sind wie in einem schacht oder ansage
ohne perspektive was läuft falsch und
was wünschen sie sich wie sollen wir mit
dieser er irgendwie nicht enden
wollenden corona barnim ihr umgehen sind
weder mittlerweile in einem stadel von
panikmache angekommen
kann ich mache machen wir schon lange
also dass das das bedeutet dass die
letzten anderthalb jahren
es gibt sicherheit zeiten in denen man
das eher verzeihen oder verstehen kann
als heute noch und
ich warte auf den frieden der sowie die
meisten menschen in diesem land es gibt
nahezu keinen grund mehr dass dennoch
weiter aus zu zögern und diese ewigen
verschiebungen der ziele das machen wir
die maßnahmen wir erhalten sie jetzt
deswegen weiter weil das haben wir
wieder ein neues ziel das haben wir dann
neues ziel jetzt ist das ziel die zwei
gesellschafter westerkamp das kann man
nicht das geht nicht wenn ich bin jemand
der ich liebe die die freiheit ich kann
akzeptieren dass die eingeschränkt ist
und dass man ich kann mich an regeln
halten gar kein problem aber es muss
dafür gute gründe geben und die werden
eben immer weniger gut und eigentlich
gibt sie wenn ich das richtig leute
diese zahlen so wie sie jetzt also nicht
mehr
es denn ihre angst nach diesen wirbel um
hashtag alles dicht machen dass wenn sie
jetzt ihre meinung sagen und sich klar
positionieren dass dann wieder sein
gegenwind auf sie zukommt kümmert sie
das
ja das gerne also das ist nicht schön
ist aber
ich habe die entscheidung bewusst
getroffen zusammen mit einigen anderen
kollegen und wir stehen dazu nach wie
vor es gibt keinen grund zurückzurudern
und
wenn jemand über das ziel hinaus
schießen sollte was dann ist auch das
nicht schlimm also wir haben die
freiheit der meinung die freiheit der
rede ist eine ganz wichtige sache und
die die fängt natürlich da an wo jemand
etwas sagt was mir nicht passt in dem
moment wo sich alle einer meinung sind
brauchten keine meinungsfreiheit
[Musik]